The Joe Rogan experience.
You got spidey sense, man.
Got It.
So one of the most humbling things
about getting older is the vision going.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I've known like from when I was like 42
I started to notice it and by the time I
was 46 I was like,
God damn.
And I think I need glasses because I
would just try to like read the computer
and I'd be doing this with my eyes,
like bulging my eyes and squinting and
trying to look at it sideways and try and
see what the fuck I was ready. It's
a weird thing. It's like, oh boy.
My ability to see the world
is fading. It happens. Yeah.
It was to the best of this, but it's
a warning sign like, hey man, this is,
you know, this is a finite
existence. Yeah. Oh,
get some shit done right now.
Right now.
Don't wait. It's going to be waiting
time. It sets a precious commodity.
Billionaires,
you can not buy one second
nine oh one second of life.
Yeah. Can't do it. Nope. It's whole price.
Anything that you're thinking about
doing and you've been putting off?
My advice is big.
Get step and get to next year.
Right now we get after it. Don't
put it off any longer. Get it done.
So do you feel like you're like
CT Fletcher 2.0 definitely.
I'm a new dude. I knew dude
with a new attitude. Yeah.
Yeah. Big Time. Oh boy. You
won't be arguing at Taylor.
The guys I used to argue with
online, Hey, I love you man.
You can hate me all you want to. I love
to see I ain't got time for hate. Yeah.
Racism or a big, I got time for none
of that. It's all foolish and I said,
it's so much bullshit and just a waste
of time and ain't even fighting. Yeah.
I'm like,
look,
if the in the transplant
experience enhanced my view,
I've always said,
we were all saying I need a bar.
My mom taught me love
everybody, but look, they took,
I have no idea the nationality
or race up the donor,
it don't matter. I hope you're right.
If you're right, it's an Asian woman.
I think that would be fantastic.
Then you could feel that,
that you would know that
and you could feel it. Man,
we that be something to be amazing. I
got to find out. How can you find out? I,
I don't, I have no idea. I want that.
Hopefully they're listening
to the Joe Rogan podcast.
Okay.